souvent quand je parle de truc qui
concerne la santé j'ai les mêmes
commentaires qui reviennent genre si je
parle d'un truc potentiellement
dangereux j'ai des non alors n'importe
quoi parce que moi je fais ça tout le
temps il m'est jamais rien arrivé donc
bon non bon alors je te le dis
tranquillement sans aucune animosité
hein mais ton cas n'est pas universel
désolé pour déterminer si quelque chose
est dangereux pour la santé ou bon pour
la santé d'ailleurs c'est pareil on
étudie la question sur un peu plus que
une personne hein déjà pour qu'une étude
soit fiable par exemple bah il faut
qu'elle soit menée sur un grand nombre
de sujets ensuite pour rester dans le
cas d'un truc dangereux c'est pas
toujours le cas pour 100 % des gens donc
si pour toi ça a pas de conséquence tant
mieux mais ça veut pas dire que ça en a
pour personne et puis un dernier truc
les choses qui touchent notre santé
souvent ça arrive petit à petit et on
s'en rend pas compte comme ça tout de
suite ça peut prendre des années donc tu
fais comme tu veux hein mais c'est pas
parce que pour l'instant tu passes entre
les gouttes que ça sera toujours le cas
bref quand on parle des gens on parle
pas de toi et tes commentaires ça aide
personne d'ailleurs c'est valable pour
tous les autres sujets en fait